[Music]
the last performance i saw before
kovid was michael mcintyre live at radio
city music hall in new york
radio city is actually a small venue for
michael
he's one of the world's most successful
stand-up comedians
and he usually does venues the size of
stadiums
these past few months have been a bit
stressful so i decided i needed a bit of
a laugh
and so i called michael and that's
exactly what we did
we laughed about many things including
his shitty wifi
this is a bit of optimism
should i force quit
i'm not very savvy i'm gonna just start
force quitting
hold on okay i'll tell you what i'm now
forced quitting
adobe flash player install manager don't
even know what that is oh yeah you don't
really need that anymore
i'm gonna force quit the calculator okay
that's
that's not doing anything either now i'm
gonna force quit my scanner
basically i just scan signed invoices uh
so that i can't do during this podcast
um no messages no more pinging
excel never used it i don't know why
it's open i don't know what to do
i don't know what to do either this is
live right this is going out live
all right here i am so tell me when you
want to start
the house and i'll have to try and be
optimistic that's what the only
requirement
is you have to be optimistic so we're
going to start now you
all right it's a bit of ready stretch
michael mcintyre the indefatigable hang
on
what does that mean
uh it means you don't get fatigued oh
fabulous um but i have also put on
weight
give me a big a big intro because to be
honest i need it as much as
this ladies and gentlemen you haven't
done a show
when was the last time you did a show
wait is that my big introduction ladies
and gentlemen this is an american thing
you have to give me a big up you've got
to tell everybody how
sensational i am no michael mcintyre is
perhaps one of the greatest comedians
that has ever lived he's unbelievably
famous
he's unbelievably funny and i cannot
believe
that he agreed to come on my little
podcast
this is the most humbled i felt with any
guest ever
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
michael mcintyre thank you very much
simon it's actually a pleasure to be
with you
today on um your wonderful podcast a bit
of optimism
um we're gonna have to have a lot of
optimism with regards to
the quality of wi-fi currently in my
house
i hate to tell you i actually missed a
lot of that intro so i'll need to do it
again
now i'll take your word for it it was
really
i mean i big upped you big time i said
you're one of the greatest comedians
that ever lived ever yes and i love the
way you're using the past tense because
the greatest comedian living i was
i used to be a comedian as you well know
and you came to one of my last
ever performances i did in new york no
it's amazing to think back
at uh what used to happen and performing
because it's been um well it's been over
a year since i've been on stage i dream
about it sometimes and i have tried a
zoom gig that's been an absolute
catastrophe
why was it a catastrophe because you
didn't have the audience energy you need
feedback time but it's really
that laughter is really key to the whole
process because that's why you do it
right you do it for the live
and i can't tell you how encouraging
laughter
i took it for granted but sitting at my
desk trying to be funny
and there was like thousands of people
watching and i had no idea whether they
were enjoying it
and also the ceo of the company he made
a speech before
me and he was the only person i could
see and
i didn't realize but he had gone he had
actually signed off he wasn't watching
the gig
so what remained was the final shot of
his face before he signed off
but i thought he was still there and i'm
here to tell you that final shot
was not a smiley one he looked
incredibly upset
because he was obviously looking you
know that face you make when you're
looking for the leave button
looking down then i started laying into
him but not laughing he wasn't even
there
it was just an image of him so yeah
these are very taxing types
how's it been for you i adjusted with my
work also
feedback matters and so i stopped giving
speeches i prefer interviews because
then i can actually engage with someone
even though i don't have an audience
you're very good with an audience simon
and you you're very funny as well you
you have a good
sprinkling of laughter in your you're
very kind and you need that it breaks a
room
you need to sprinkle the best speakers
will sprinkle comedy in there just to
bind the audience together at key
moments it's vital isn't it
i think that comedians play a more vital
role than people realize
stephen colbert said once that you can't
be angry when you're laughing
i think you're overlooking tickling
you have an enormous amount of rage
that's actually true
still you're laughing your head off but
other than tickling
you can't be angry and you can't be sad
when you're laughing
and i remember when covid first happened
when we first went into lockdown
all these funny videos and all these
memes just sort of
pouring out that we were all forwarding
to each other and
laughing out loud and it sort of really
did help when we
hit so much uncertainty is what was
going to happen and can we touch
the milk we just bought for fear of
death
i think we've sort of comes in terms of
the fact that you can't get it from
surfaces correct
but yes shopping and and cleaning
while you were shopping and then
cleaning essentially buying cleaning
equipment and then using
other cleaning equipment to clean the
cleaning
you've got to clean the next one and
then you've got to buy that one to clean
that one
is going to clean this one you know
there was endless cleaning and rubber
gloves and it was a very well it still
is very scary
but yes you're right there was a lot of
comedy it took me a while to engage
comedically i didn't find it
particularly funny
for a long time still don't have you
avoided it son
i have fortunately avoided covid yes i
have not had it have you had a vaccine
i have i just had my second shot last
week fully
facts i'm fully vaccinated it's i mean
it's a thing my favorite thing is like
when somebody says did you get facts i'm
like uh yeah
and then they always ask madonna pfizer
like it matters
and i do the same thing i go which ones
you get and they go johnson and johnson
okay cool moderna okay cool like i have
no opinion
you say okay cool but then you walk away
and delete them from your phone
that is an unfortunate follow-up
question it's almost like we're slightly
worried that the future of society is
going to be divided into these subsets
right
of like like advisors can only marry
fighters it's
they're having a mixed wedding it's a
modern and fizer yeah
when you complete it's in a bridal groom
okay on the left
did you were you able to avoid it i
didn't avoid it i got it in november i
mean it wasn't awful i was very
fortunate because but it's it's scary
many people obviously have more than
many people know um because you go
through it and then there's that sort of
weight to see if you either get a lot
worse or get better right
um so yeah i got it it lingered a really
long time
thankfully i was the only one who got it
in my house weirdly i got it my
housekeeper got it and my wife
didn't so you can read into that however
let's just say a lot of questions which
i coughed away
yeah i just i'll tell you in a minute
i've got my way through that and luckily
i think i got away with it
um but yes and i'm getting the vaccine i
think on sunday so this is happening
which one are you getting well i'm gonna
get the
i think the fight i think you don't get
to choose but i think it's the pfizer
my wife's had the astrazeneca last week
so obviously um
i'm just hoping the housekeeper gets the
fires
one of the things that's been impressed
me you've been really actually
productive during
covert you wrote a book yeah i actually
it's been all right
i wrote a book i wrote a second
autobiography i mean what
it begs the question how does one write
a second autobiography
well it's exactly the same as the first
or you're just picking up where the last
one left off
no it's the same it's actually the same
words it's just a different color
that's why it was so easy yes it picks
up where the last one left off
my life volume two that well yes because
the first one was called
life and laughing and i wanted to call
it more life and more laughing
it with a view to a follow-up still
alive and still like
and then the final incomplete
installment my deathbed
nearly done perfectly fairly alive and
dribbling but the publisher thought it
wasn't good to do that so at the moment
it's called a funny life
and uh they like it so that's good
that's good at the moment it's all the
grammar and stuff which is like
i didn't realize i was so hopeless like
words i literally had no idea i felt
wrong the whole book
lead i didn't know lead was led
yeah i think we were taught it was lead
wasn't it maybe
i mean i write books on leadership and
i'm actually not 100 sure
well i wrote a book on leadership
i put this thing i like doing when i
just put things on their own line i hate
too much text
yeah you and me both just take a breath
and take this in
so i'll just put it on its own also it
means i end up with more pages
it's like a poem i like writing in a
manner that helps people
read it the way i want it said you know
ellipses and spaces and gaps so that
you're forced to take the breath so
you're forced to take in whatever line
is the next line i love doing that
well it reflects the way you speak and
it's your voice and people hear your
voice and everyone can write simon let's
be honest i mean writing is just
it's just saying stuff but written down
isn't it i mean it's not it's
it's no great shape no i think it's
different because otherwise everybody
would just talk into a tape recorder and
then have it transcribed and
that would be a book and those make bad
books right well i'm sorry i wish i
hadn't
done it that way
but that's wonderful i think that's so
fantastic that you spent the time to
write a book
and you developed a tv show like how can
you say you've been unproductive
i don't know how i know it on paper it
looks like i've been very productive
i had an idea for a tv show in the bath
i don't know why i always mentioned that
i was in the bath but just because i was
in above
i literally thought i'm going to come up
with a tv show idea um i wanted to come
up with a game show so i came up well i
came up with two
um one of them was awful is it is it
something you can talk about publicly
well yes it's on the back burner i mean
we can you can bring it off the back if
it was just a quiz show where the other
person has to quickly
ask the question and know the answer
so it would be me versus you i would
just give you a subject you have to come
up with a question okay let's try it
let's try it
okay so you're gonna give me a subject
and i have to come up with a question
and an answer for myself
yes but i've got to answer it but you
have to know the answer ah and you've
only got five seconds to do
oh gee the theory here is that under
pressure you're gonna say something
silly
okay to be honest this is an idea i've
not voiced outside of
once after this bath but
okay so i'll give you the subject okay
oh um
i've got okay you see it's even hard to
think of it
i'm gonna give you the subject of um oh
my goodness
of podcasts you've got five seconds how
many podcasts have you done
since before this one you know after you
have to know the answer i know the
answer
you know how many podcasts i've done
before this one you know that
yeah now i'm gonna have to guess i don't
know three
one
okay as you can see this i do doesn't
necessarily have
i would like to try one side there okay
so now let me do it to you okay i've got
one for you now okay
okay um let's do
zoos
name a zoo
in in london
the london zoo that's the correct answer
we get a point there could potentially
be fun in this game
[Laughter]
and so we made 10 of those we're making
16 more and it's going to be on
nbc i think early next year oh that's
fantastic oh i have to see if i can
watch it on bbc iplayer or something
like that
it's it's a really really fun show we're
going to as i say we're making more in a
couple of weeks
that's really good so i want to
understand how you wrote a book
devised and produced and executed a tv
show
are you sitting writing jokes like you
used to i don't write jokes
i tend to write notes of things that
make me laugh and then i just perform
them over and over again in little gigs
and build them up so
home life has always been very relaxed
and um
you know not high pressure and overly
creative and i'm just sort of dad
and a husband here so no that sort of
disappeared which is awkward and i
really wanted to come back
and with regards to working um i need to
keep busy
and now that i finished the book and
finished the tv show i
can feel myself getting a bit sort of
confused about stuff and
inarticulate and going slightly mad
but yeah everybody was forced to a pivot
that's an american
yes we're all pivoting yeah yeah i
didn't know about pivoting until an
american mentioned it was a possibility
so i pivoted
away from stand up and started doing the
tv show and
yeah i went back to writing a book and
writing's a lovely thing because you're
cocoon in your own bubble you can write
rubbish but then fix it the next day
it's a different type of creativity do
you want to go back to life as you had
it before covet or do you think that
this will
permanently change the way you live your
showbiz life
well we have to appreciate things more i
mean it would be criminal not to
appreciate everything
should the world come back because i
think everyone was quite excited about
appreciating the small things at the
beginning
but now it's going on and on and on it's
getting really really serious it's like
how far into this are we is this year
one of five
is it you're one of ten is it one are we
nearly out yeah
you know every time you get a bit of
good news suddenly there's a triple
mutated
something coming in from in here it's
coming in from brazil and
it's just terrifying it's humanity
versus mother nature
it absolutely is and there's so much to
learn from it but whether we will
i'd love to find out which means it
would be over but you want to go back to
sort of doing your gigs and doing your
shows
like you're craving going back to the
way life was or do you think that
something happened because for me
i realized that i was on this hamster
wheel and i was enjoying
the speed that i was running but one of
the things that coveted did for me is i
looked i was like oh my god
i wasn't running fast i was just trying
to keep up and covet stopped the wheel
the terrible thing is when you're trying
to keep up with other people and you
can't be doing that what a waste of life
that is
and that's the lesson i've tried to
learn because competition is a natural
instinct it's a drive which is good
um but ultimately it's kind of
meaningless because like you said if
you're always chasing something if
you're always
i think i think that people struggle
with is how much people
need something to look forward to and
not knowing the future
is really damaging to that because
living in the here and now in the
present it's not an easy thing to do
we're not used to that what we're used
to
doing is knowing something good is
coming or thinking it's going to be good
or
even if it's a goal it could be a
holiday or it could be i need to achieve
that that's such a great insight that's
like telling your kids
we're going to disneyland on this date
and like the kids count the days down
the excitement you know they have to get
their chores done and get certain things
so they can go to disneyland because
there's conditions put on the trip
but if you just said we're going on
holiday one day
it's kind of a little unnerving actually
and that's what we have we keep being
told we're coming out of this and then
the the target keeps moving
with regards to holidays it's
fascinating hub that is what people are
desperate for
but what is a holiday it's such a budget
it's a change it's a break and
every single person who came on my game
show
when i said to them what would you do if
you won that's every single person
not just the holiday they wanted to go
to where you just said
disney they wanted to go through those
gates into fantasyland if everyone's
smiling at you saying welcome home
and dressed up as smiley characters
and just stay there for a bit to not
have to worry that was walt disney's
vision
which is a place to escape depression
and sadness and the drudgery and
greatness of real life
and come to this place that was always
bright and sunny and fun i mean that was
his vision whether it's a reality or
just a fantasy it
keeps people going that's one of the
many things has been taken away
but you still haven't answered the
question do you want to go back to the
life you had
before covet or do you think that there
will be changes to the cadence or the
way you live your life because of covet
it's weird because i i'm always
complaining so when i'm working i want
to be at home and when i'm at home i
want to be working you know
but that's also how i function it's also
what you know how i find things funny
it's
it's that kind of mania of neurosis that
creates comedy
i know because i've had a lot of time to
think about it but i'm happy i'm
happiest but i'm being creative
and i've come up with something good and
i was able to do that a bit
under these circumstances but really
nothing beats
live performance and the instantaneous
reaction because
it's very cathartic because it washes
everything away you know
everybody worries about how they're
being perceived are they on good form
are they thinking right to people like
me
nothing is more magical than just saying
something to an audience of people and
everybody
you know confirms it and laughs with you
and it's just it's instant feedback
it's not like you have to write a book
and you have to put it out this one
person likes it another person does it
why is you know you're on amazon why is
that person give me a two-star review
it's just like
that i said something funny i thought it
was funny it was they're all laughing
then i followed up with more stuff that
just came out of my head and i didn't
have to think about it
and it's just joyous and it fuels me it
keeps me
keeps me going and without it i always
go a bit weird and now i've been forced
to be without it so
i've had just sort of self-confidence
i'm here to tell you still looking
i wonder if comedy will work socially
distance because one of the things that
happens when somebody laughs everybody
laughs it's like
things are funnier when you're with a
friend my test is something is
really funny is if i can watch by myself
and laugh
out loud that that's like the greatest
test of something's really funny because
things are funnier with your friends
and so if you're socially distanced the
question is is will the laughter spread
across the audience
like it does in a packed house but it's
obviously going to be more difficult
and of course the funnier you are the
more dangerous it is because
i mean if you physically laugh
[Music]
breathing in and out and then you're
leaving early you know that's standing
ovation
it costs us seriously um
but i mean look at tonight there simon i
mean and then think about masks i mean
you're performing to people
that's right you can't even see them
smiling you just hope they have smiling
eyes
listen i'm a huge one for resting faces
i mean i'm always scanning the audience
and if anybody looks miserable
i start to really i focus in on them why
why are they not smiling why are they
not on the edge of their seat why are
they
what do they do why are they even here
do they hate me i start to lose my mind
over it
but now you you know that you can't even
see their face you know their faces are
behind the mask their social distance
i mean it's like all of my worst things
in regards to performance
you and i have different strategies when
i'm on a stage
and of course i'm scanning and i can see
somebody looking very angry and
disapproving
and then i see somebody else who's
nodding and smiling and agreeing with
everything i'm saying
i fixate on the person who's nodding and
agreeing with me because it makes me i'm
like ooh
this is going great and my my energy
goes up and my confidence goes up when i
focus on the person who's
scowling at me i'm like this is over
like i can't do this like
and then i spend my whole time trying to
convince one person well i can't cope
when people go to the loo because i'm
waiting for them to come back because
i'm always thinking they might
walk out sometimes i accidentally i'll
be a mid-joke and they'll come back in
and go
because i was so thrilled that it was
that they were so desperate to go to the
louis
it's not that they've literally just
walked out and not only that i see
sometimes they're in a couple i'm like
i'm so
awful they've left the show they've left
their part
oh no they're back i'm fine no i'm
definitely viewing it in a more negative
way which is why
honestly i've had the best gigs of my
life when i can't see the audience i
always ask
for the spotlight just hit me in the
face i don't want to see anything
i mean especially when i do the bigger
rooms i can't see a single person and
you just
you relax and you just you just you're
dealing now with one
noise it's like you're like one animal
is laughter
as opposed to lots of individuals i find
this so fascinating because we are the
total opposite i always request the
house lights as bright as possible so i
can see the people
so that i can make eye contact with
somebody so i can talk to a person if
i'm talking to a blank void
i don't know what to do my worst gigs
are when the spotlight's on them
and the house lights are off well you're
obviously a much more positive person
but i would like to plug mine a bit of
pessimism which is
also going to be on apple itunes or
whatever it is
[Laughter]
also the pandoring is cut short our
burgeoning friendship i mean
we've only met a few times you saw me in
new york after my show
um and of course that's when this was
all that's right i came to see your show
right what was it in march of last year
right it was february
february so it's right when this thing
was just beginning and we was just
hearing the first
reports of it in the west and i came to
see your show at radio city which by the
way was
fantastic that was the last show i did
and i started that show
by saying as a joke this could be the
last show
i do and it was for a lot for a long
long time and
ongoing i mean i mean absolutely wild
but it's an experiment you know if you
look at aspects of it like an experiment
and try and get
the positives out of it like when i
finally get back on stage and
and you know and like i said earlier
we've got we've got to learn from it so
you're going to help people do that
that's why you're so brilliant
is that you can get people thinking
about the right things which is so
important
and also let's not forget that the world
didn't seem to be going that great
anyway before
as well it's not like everyone was
flying everyone was quite stressed
not really understanding social media is
going crazy i do think that when there's
this kind of massive disruption
i'm a great believer in balance in all
clouds there are silver linings
and for all of the stresses and strains
that we've gone through because of covid
and the murder of george floyd and what
that started
that good comes out of things and even
though i think we're in a period of
extreme stress we don't know
how things are going to pan out there's
a momentum and an appetite for things
like police reform in the united states
and really focusing on race relations in
the united states and other places
around the world
and what does happiness mean i think you
know i think that this is a big
opportunity for us to reevaluate
happiness is not just how much money we
make in the promotion we get but it's
the time we spend with our families and
the time we have to ourselves and doing
creative things
the balance took too far for kovid but i
think it forced us to reevaluate
and and i think that's a ultimately i
think a lot of good will come out of
this period of darkness and uncertainty
but that's the optimist in me that's
very optimistic
but having said all that when we are
allowed to
leave our homes for good and this is all
over
i'm gonna feel like such a loser if i'm
ever staying in
can you imagine having i mean i feel
like i have to go after them
can you imagine having to say the words
yeah i'm just going to stay in and have
a quiet one i was like i think
we've got our fix well i'm an introvert
so i've been planning my whole life for
this pandemic
i always like talking about phones with
you how are you feeling about that the
whole um
obsession with with mobiles because the
problem of course with the pandemic is
we've been forced
onto our phones and to give up any sense
of of rules with
kids and stuff it's just like what else
are you gonna do
how much does your usage go i mean your
screen time my personal content
i like the phone i saw one of the things
that was great about covet is people
actually picked up the phone
like people who would never dream of
phoning and would just text were
actually making calls to hear the voice
of another human being i love that
so that i think is great you know i
don't think technology is bad i mean i
don't have
i'm not anti-phone i think it's the
balance of technology in our lives and i
think a lot of people were spending
times with their family and watching tv
you know which is great and people
didn't have the phone at the dinner
table they put it away
well i've certainly been on my phone a
lot more than well are you texting
friends are you playing games
what are you doing no i'm just sort of
scrolling around the internet
garbage i mean at night the terrible
thing is i'm sort of embarrassed about
my wife and i are both on our phones and
sometimes i wake up in the night and
just start looking at my phone and
and i'll catch her doing it there's a
sort of glow you get to sort of give
away
bedtime glow in the middle of the night
and i sort of build a sort of pillow
wall between us so that i can hide the
fact that i'm
on my phone for ages sometimes i'm
holding it lying down
over my head reading my phone and i fall
as this is happening
at least for occasion i fall asleep and
the phone drops out of my hand
you know sometimes the remote from that
of your hand hands on my face
wakes me up and then i just carry on
scrub
i think that is addiction by the way
my son his bedroom is above us
and we know that he's gone to sleep
because this is terrible
the phone falls out of his hand and
lands on the floor we can hear it
hitting
the ceiling and i'll be like oh luke's
just gone to sleep and we hear it go
crash and it's like oh he's gone oh
bless
him it's terrible it is terrible but you
know
isn't it all but you know we'll address
that michael
it's such a joy to talk to you i just i
adore it this has made my week
i just love the way you see the world i
just love talking to you
it's a constant constant giggle i just
adore it
it's been very fun i'm sorry about the
wi-fi um but i think it just about held
that
look i think we've all become a lot more
patient with people's children running
through meetings
and frozen wi-fi and turning on cat
filters and not knowing how to turn them
off
because you know i think it's actually
made us just a little more empathetic
and so
i have empathy for your shitty wi-fi
thank you so much for having me on and
you're brilliant and you help people
think in the right way
and um you're an excellent person
and on that note thanks ty you're the
best you're the absolute best
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other